but um first and foremost with with the
Rwanda policy the Church of England
describes it as immoral some people
might suggest that's perhaps over egging
the pudding somewhat what's your view
well we think this policy is unworkable
and we're seeing that play out over
these few days it's incredibly expensive
it's going to cost possibly over a
million pounds per per unsuccessful or
successful Refugee going uh to to Rwanda
and we do think it's unethical and it's
quite unbritish actually because you
know we've been known around the world
as a safe haven for those genuinely
fleeing persecution and War it's been
part of our makeup in this country for
decades and we just don't think this
policy is going to work on on any of
those those levels and it's not going to
stop the illegal trafficking of people
across the channel either but at least
we do know from the high court and
indeed the court of appeal yesterday
that it's not illegal well we try to to
make it not legal by opposing it in
Parliament that's that's where we sit
and that's what we try to to do but
there are things the government could be
doing
um that they're not doing to stop uh the
the continuation of huge numbers of
people coming making that dangerous
Crossing across the channel and they're
not doing it explain then the the
immorality in this particular policy I
mean our correspondent Shaggy matariki
has been looking at the accommodation uh
that has been set aside for for these
Asylum Seekers to live in it doesn't
look like there's anything that you
could possibly complain about there
Rwanda itself has been making massive
strides in terms of its human rights
record over the past couple of years so
so where is the immorality well
unethical I think is I I use but I mean
look I think the point is is that even
those who are successful
um with their Asylum applications so
they have got a a strong case why they
fled persecution they fled war and
they're looking for a safe haven here in
the UK even those whose applications
would be successful are not then allowed
back into the country they have to stay
um
would you be happy with the policy if
someone who filled their Asylum claim
here popped on a plane to Rwanda is
successful there would you be happy with
the policy if they could come back well
I don't think it's workable either that
that's the issue and we're seeing that
play out here it's incredibly expensive
that that money would be better spent I
mean firstly they are cutting the budget
of the National Crime agency the very
agency whose job it is to seek out these
Smugglers and stop them from what
they're doing cutting it by 20 we've got
a huge backlog in Asylum claims in this
country that's why we're seeing people
uh for years on end being housed in in
expensive hotels and things like that
because their applications aren't being
processed we haven't got the return
arrangements with France and Belgium and
so on that we used to have so when
people who haven't got a right to be in
this country who's whose claims are
unsuccessful we can't return them in the
way that we that we used to do and and
we what we want to make it illegal for
these Smuggler gangs to advertise on
social media which at the moment they
can so there's lots the government could
be doing that aren't doing and we fear I
think and we're seeing this play out
that this is a a deliberately
controversial policy designed to take
attention away from the government's
other problems and get us all talking
about something else well let's talk
about something that I'm sure you
identify as a problem for the for the
government the Northern Ireland protocol
and the and the changes that the
government is wishing to bring in I mean
the European Union is saying that that
it cannot be renegotiated but even you I
I assume would concede that there are
issues around the Good Friday agreement
when power sharing is not taking place
demonstrably installment right now and
businesses are complaining about there
being a border in the Irish sea so to
speak what's your view well there are
issues uh with the way the the protocol
is being implemented uh so that there
are things that could be resolved and
they are within the the kind of broad
remit of the protocol to be able to to
resolve them there are those Avenues to
do that let's not forget that the the
Northern Ireland protocol is is a
fundamental part of the withdrawal
agreement as leaving uh brexit it was
negotiated by Boris Johnson it's his uh
deal he signed on the dotted line and I
think the issue here is one of tactics
the government are now pressing the
nuclear button at the very sort of
beginning really of this sort of uh
process of renegotiation and that's
breaking down trust completely rather
silly when the dup said you know what
that's enough to get us back into
parachuting installment well I don't
know that it is going to be enough and
there's obviously many other parts if it
is and they head back in on that basis
doesn't it doesn't it you know be
justified well there are there are other
issues here you know we do we do need to
have a a good working relationship with
the European Union as well we don't want
to start some kind of trade War because
we press the nuclear button a unilateral
nuclear button to say an agreement we
signed up to only a few months ago we
now want to renegon that doesn't show us
uh in a very good light internationally
just at the point we've got a cost of
living crisis in this country problems
with Supply chains problems with food
imports energy Imports and so on we
don't want to make that worse right now
and also with the war in Ukraine we we
want a united front across the whole of
Europe not this division so again it's
this is very poor tactics from the
government I think with good leadership
building trust State craft and you know
really
negotiating hard on behalf of the
government we could we could resolve
many of these issues I mean you
mentioned um good leadership there I
mean it's secure St armor where did it
all go wrong I mean when the deputy
leader of the party is telling them that
you need to say bit more well into his
performances that suggests that things
are not going entirely to plan well I I
would disagree with that very very
strongly I think when you look at the
journey that kirst armor has taken the
labor party on in the last uh two years
when we came out of that 2019 general
election defeat where the conservatives
got a massive majority of 80 seats it
was labeledated by Dunham police
investigated by the standards
commissioner for someone who portrays
himself as whiter than white this is not
a good look right now well as I say I
mean we've come a long way in a short
space of time from our worst general
election defeat to now being you know
consistently sort of ahead in the polls
people uh trust us people are looking at
us afresh but are we complacent about
that absolutely not do we think that
just because the government are having a
a terrible time which they which they
are of their own making does that mean
it will all fall in our laps no we don't
think that and kirst armor is the is the
first person to remind us all of that
every week at the shadow cabinet which
I'm sure he'll do very shortly at this
week's Shadow cabinet as well